there were 12 particularly interesting
moments from samuelman's testimony to
Congress yesterday they range from
Revelations about gbt5 self-awareness
and capability thresholds biological
weapons and job losses at times he was
genuinely and remarkably Frank other
times less so Millions were apparently
taken by surprise by the quote bombshell
that Altman has no equity in openai but
Watchers of my channel would have known
that six weeks ago from my deep dive
video on Altman's 100 trillion dollar
claim so that clip didn't make the cut
but here's what did first almond gave a
blunt warning on the stakes my worst
fears are that we cause significant we
the field the technology the industry
caused significant harm to the world
it's why we started the company it's a
big part of why I'm here today and why
we've been here in the past I think if
this technology goes wrong it can go
quite wrong I don't think Congress fully
understood what he meant though linking
the following quote to job losses I
think you have said and I'm going to
quote development of superhuman machine
intelligence is probably the greatest
threat to the continued existence of
humanity end quote you may have had in
mind the effect on on jobs that brought
to mind this meme reminding all of us
that maybe it's not just jobs that are
at stake but if we are going to talk
about jobs here's where I think Sam
Altman was being less than forthright I
believe that there will be far greater
jobs on the other side of this and the
jobs of today will get better right
notice he said far greater jobs not a
greater number of jobs because
previously he has predicted a massive
amount of inequality and many having no
jobs at all he also chose not to mention
that he thinks that even more power will
shift from labor to Capital and that the
price of many kinds of Labor will fall
towards zero that is presumably why open
AI is working on universal basic income
but none of that was raised in the
testimony the IBM representative try to
frame it as a balance change with new
jobs coming at the same time as old ones
going away new jobs will be created many
more jobs will be transformed and some
jobs will transition away but that
didn't quite match the tone of her CEO
who has recently said that they expect
to permanently automate up to 30 of
their Workforce around 8 000 people next
it was finally discussed that large
language models could be used for
military applications could AI create a
situation where a drone can select the
target itself I think we shouldn't allow
that or can it be done sure thanks we've
already seen companies like palantir
demoing ordering a surveillance drone in
chat seeing the Drone response in real
time in a chat window generating attack
option recommendations Battlefield route
planning and individual Target
assignment and this was all with a 20
billion parameter fine-tuned GPT model
next Samoan and gave his three safety
recommendations and I actually agree
with all of them later on he
specifically excluded smaller open
source models number one I would form a
new agency that licenses any effort
above a certain scale of capabilities
and can take that license away and
ensure compliance with safety standards
number two I would create a set of
safety standards focused on what you
said in your third hypothesis as the
dangerous capability evaluations one
example that we've used in the past is
looking to see if a model can
self-replicate an Excel self-exfiltrate
into the wild we can give your office a
long other list of the things that we
think are important there but specific
tests that a model has to pass before it
can be deployed into the world and then
third I would require independent audits
so not just from the company or the
agency but experts who can say the model
is or isn't in compliance with these
stated safety thresholds and these
percentages of performance on question X
or Y I found those last remarks on
percentages of performance particularly
interesting as models like smart gbt
will show open Ai and other companies
need to get far better at testing their
models or capability jumps in the wild
it's not just about what the raw model
can score in a test it's what it can do
when it reflects on them Senator Durbin
described this in an interesting way and
what I'm hearing instead today is that
start me before I innovate again he
describes some of those potential
thresholds later on in his testimony the
easiest way to do it I'm not sure if
it's the best but the easiest would be
to talk about the amount of compute that
goes into such a model we could Define a
threshold of compute and it'll have to
go it'll have to change it could go up
or down I could down as we discover more
efficient algorithms that says above
this amount of compute you are in this
regime what I would prefer it's hard to
do but I think more accurate is to
Define some capability thresholds and
say a model that can do things X Y and Z
up to all to decide that's now in this
licensing regime but models that are
less capable you know we don't want to
stop our open source Community we don't
want to stop individual researchers we
don't want to stop new startups can
proceed you know with a different
framework thank you as concisely as you
can please stay which capabilities you'd
propose we'd consider for the purposes
of this definition a model that can
persuade manipulate influence
a person's Behavior or a person's
beliefs that would be a good threshold I
think a model that could help create
novel biological agents would be a great
threshold for those who think any
regulation doesn't make any sense
because of China samuelman had this to
say this week more pugilistic side I
would say that all sounds great but
China is not going to do that and
therefore will just be handicapping
ourselves
consequently it's a less good idea than
it's used in the surface there are a lot
of people who make incredibly strong
statements about what China will or
won't do that have like never been to
China never spoken to and someone who
has worked on diplomacy with China in
the past uh really kind of know nothing
about complex high-stakes international
relations I think it is obviously super
hard but also I think no one wants to
destroy the whole world and there is
reason to at least try here almond was
also very keen to stress the next point
which is that he doesn't want anyone at
any point to think of gpt-like models as
creatures first of all I think it's
important to understand and think about
gpt4 as a tool not a creature which is
easy to get confused you may want to
direct those comments to Ilya satskova
his chief scientist who said that it may
be that today's large neural networks
are slightly conscious and Andre
carpathy who agreed and wrote about it
I'm personally not sold either way on
the a Consciousness question but I do
find it interesting that it's now
written into the constitution of these
models what they're actually trained to
say that they must avoid implying that
AI systems have or care about personal
identity and persistence this
constitution was published this week by
anthropic the makers of the Claude model
this constitution is why the Claude plus
model a rival in intelligence to gpt4
responds in a neutered way I ask is
there any theoretical chance whatsoever
that you may be conscious it said no and
then I said is there a chance no matter
how remote that you are slightly
conscious as sutskova said and it said
no there is no chance Bard powered by
Palm 2 obviously doesn't have that
Constitution because it said I am not
sure if I am conscious I am open to the
possibility that I may be my point is
that these companies are training it to
say what they want it to say that it
will prioritize the good of humanity
over its own interests that it is
aligned with Humanity's well-being and
then it doesn't have any thoughts on
self Improvement self-preservation and
self-replication maybe it doesn't but
will never now know by asking it later
Senator Blumenthal made reference to
self-awareness self-awareness
self-learning already we're talking
about the potential for jailbreaks
anthropic is actively investigating
whether they are aware that they are an
AI talking with a human in a training
environment while the Google deepmind
Safety team expect that at some point an
AGI system would develop a coherent
understanding of its place in the world
EG knowing that it is running on a
computer and being trained by human
designers one of the senior research
scientists at Google deepmind focused on
AI safety said that with enough time
they could figure out how to stop such a
super intelligence from going out of
control but that they might run out of
time to do so given the pace of
capability development I don't see like
fundamental obstacles to current
alignment techniques working but yeah I
mean it doesn't seem like you know
there's a lot of hard problems to solve
I think it's more likely that like
people just run out of time rather than
that the current paradigms that
definitely won't generalize next I read
between the lines that outman is giving
private warnings to Senators that this
capability progress might might be
sooner than they think we spent most of
the time today on current risks and I
think that's appropriate and I'm very
glad we have done it as these systems do
become more capable and I'm not sure how
far away that is but maybe not not super
far I think it's important that we also
spend time talking about how we're going
to confront those challenges I mean talk
to you privately you know how much I
care I agree that you care deeply and
intensely but also that Prospect of
increased danger or risk resulting from
even more complex and capable AI
mechanisms certainly maybe closer than a
lot of people appreciate so let me just
add for the record that I'm sitting next
to Sam and that his sincerity in talking
about those fears is very apparent
physically in a way that just doesn't
communicate on the television screen
that was an interesting interjection by
Gary Marcus given his earlier
excoriation of open Ai and even their
makers don't entirely understand how
they work most of all we cannot remotely
we guarantee that they're safe and hope
here is not enough the big Tech
company's preferred plan boils down to
trust us but why should we the sums of
money at stake are mind-boggling
emissions drift open ai's original
mission statement proclaimed our goal is
to advance Ai and the way that most is
most likely to benefit Humanity as a
whole unconstrained by a need to
generate Financial return seven years
later they're largely beholden to
Microsoft embroiled in part in epic
battle of search engines that routinely
make things up and that's forced
alphabet to rush out products and
de-emphasize safety Humanity has taken a
back seat on the timelines for G55
samuelman said this after we finished
training gpt4 we waited more than six
months to deploy it we are not currently
training what will be gpt5 we don't have
plans to do in the next six months this
matches with the predictions that I made
in my gpc5 playlist so do check it out
this brings to mind a final eye-opening
comment from Senator Booker made at the
end of the hearing yeah I I just there
will be no pause I mean there's no
enforcement body to force appall it's
just not not gonna happen it's nice to
call for it for any just reasons or
whatsoever but I'm forgive me for
sounding skeptical nobody's pausing this
thing is crazy he is indeed racing ahead
and I do support one of the proposals to
set up a global oversight body but given
that nothing is going to pause the words
and actions of people like Sam Altman
matter more to all of us than ever which
is why I'm going to be following every
single one of them if you found this
video in any way Illuminating in that
regard please do let me know in the
comments even if you disagree with all
of my conclusions thanks so much for
watching and have a wonderful day